Khiếp nạn dùn đức, Đài lộ dinh vọng uống trà phót tức tục xuất hiện nhiều văn chụt, tư dân có để quay bà.
Mới đây, xanh bọng của Manchester United đã bị thánh trà ăn tận thực phẩm đánh giá 2 trên năm sau,
vì nhiều khu bật bình thậm si có cả phân chụt.
Đường biết, bởi thế là này được phát hiện ở khu bực dân, quay ma tự trọt và thậm si cả những phòng nghĩ các cấp có giá khoảng sấu trăm bản, hơn 14.5.
Chứ đó, xanh nhà của vị đỏ của gây xong sau khi xả tình trọng đức chú xuống như thác, tại khán đại và các phòng phay đồ.
Mới nhận sự việc xuất phát tự hệ thống Hoài Tray đã xuống cấp tự lâu khiến các của đội viên phải hát phang,
Ôi chào phót đặc sử dụng.
Tức trạng xuống cấp nghiêm trọng này từng được Cristino, đồ để cấp trong cuộc phòng vẫn bản ánh hành hiểu khu trọng 2.5.
Anh chiên xè, từ hộ bơi, bể xục phòng gien cho đến nhà bếp mỏ thứ dưới không hề thay đổi xói 2 thực kỳ trước,
khi anh còn là một tay năng chế, vắt đầu sự việc tại đây.
Tông tin này khiến nhiều người hôm qua chết tự hộ hỏi cảm thấy số hộ,
mời sân của Trà Phót không chỉ là biểu tự của bống đà anh,
mà còn là nha của đội bống lớn hẳng đầu tiên giới.